please stand for the chairman of thanet
District Council
good evening councilors officers and
members of the public please be seated
right
[Music]
John the please be seated bit now
good evening members and officers with
Council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council
if the fire alarm is activated please
vacate the building via the emergency
exits
I advise that a filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured I urge
therefore anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening
and I can't see anyone so any film
you're recording will not be permitted
for any item of business we're exempt or
confidential information is considered
following exclusion of the present
public from the meeting
with a respect to restriction on the use
of mobile phones with everyone present
please ensure that the mobile phones are
turned to silent I did that my own
before I came in and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
the chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress
so we'll move straight on to uh before I
do I'll just mention that I've lost the
sight in my right eye temporarily
I'm on the road to recovery so if I
don't see you indicate make a point of
waving again and I'll certainly
hopefully with a help of democratic
Services I will pick you up
yes councilor Auburn yeah thank you
thank you chair can I just give you a
slight bit of advice to you and not to
look through the keyholes again and then
you'll be you'll be fine after that
well thank you very much indeed for the
council opener please we're in festive
cheer
counselor Piper thank you very much
chairman uh in that uh spirit of
Christmas I was wondering if it might be
a suggestion if you move to the extreme
right
um and then you'll be able to see
everybody who's anywhere near left of
extreme right
all right all right that's enough of it
let's move on to agenda item one
apologies for absence I've received
apologies from Council of ference Nixie
Gregory Everett and Paul Moore do I have
any other apologies yes yeah
apologies
thank you very much councilor fellows
any others
councilor Curry councilor and from
councilor Pat Moore
councilor Pat Moore
I said Dennis councilor Linda Potts
councilor Linda Potts
thanks very much that's great thank you
very much indeed members
announcements agenda item three I've not
been informed of any announcements it
says here and actually I haven't
gender item three Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest this evening
and no one is indicating a gender item
four minutes of the previous meeting
gender item four a minister the
reconvene council meeting of September
2022 I move the minutes of the reconvene
meeting of the council held on the 8th
of September 2022 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice chairs
check on that chair do members agree
thank you
gender item 4B minutes of extraordinary
meeting of Council of the 13th of
October 2022 I move that the minutes of
the extraordinary meeting of the council
held on the 13th of October October 2022
be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chair please second
second that chair two members agree
thank you
gender item five petitions the result of
one petition is being reported back to
council this evening in accordance with
Council procedure rule 12.
and agenda item 5A the report back is on
the Winter Garden petition
this report is for members information
only
so there's no there's no it's really an
opportunity for anyone to say anything
they'd like to but there's no necessity
for that
do I have members position to carry on
I do thank you gender item where are we
six
questions from the press and public
there have been three questions received
from the press and public in accordance
with Council procedure rule number 13.
please know that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak on the
question
could the questioner please only state
the name of the cabinet member to whom
the question is put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
are submitting to the council
so agenda item 6A question number one
from a member of the public regarding
hydrogen filling points and please
welcome Ms Gibson to the meeting could
you please make your way to the
microphone Miss Gibson
should I I'm supposed to sit
um
okay
um chair may I beg your Indulgence for
me to include some a small bit of extra
information that I uh received today
that is important to my position
well so far as it's not too long yes I'm
happy to indulge that this evening thank
you very much
I would like to ask TDC to initiate or
facilitate the development and provision
of hydrogen filling stations in thanet
TDC has declared a climate emergency and
signed up to carbon Zero by 2030 as I
understand electric vehicles are not the
answer and also are unaffordable to so
many people and businesses here working
on extremely low budgets
and conversion means a much lower cost
than replacing existing vehicles and is
vastly more sustainable
today I have spoken that with the
director of soguard hydrogen producers
and have learned that we are in an
excellent situation to facilitate this
because all that is required is two
megawatts of Renewable Power which we
have
to earn power to facilitate the
conversion and one containerized
electrolysis machine which costs 1.5
million per machine uh Miss Gibson I I
must cut you off there I mean that is
good background information but I didn't
expect you to take it quite as far as
you have done could you move on to the
words of your question please
um I beg the council to support the
development of
um uh hydrogen filling
um points so that we can have
um enable
um vehicles to be converted Gibson could
you please ask your question I have the
wording of your question here oh right
there you go thank you so much hydrogen
filling points are required in thanet
hydrogen conversion is the affordable
and Speedy means for the most polluting
vehicles trucks and vans to become
carbon neutral and to help found it
achieve its commitment to reducing
carbon emissions for this to be feasible
we need to have hydrogen filling points
can the council facilitate this a-s-a-p
thank you thank you very much indeed
Miss Gibson uh you will appreciate
everybody that I do try to allow
everybody the opportunity
um since we're a democracy to say what
they have to say and within limits I do
like to enable a certain amount of
background
um and I feel I did in the case here
um however we now have the full wording
of the question I turned councilor
bayford
I would just make the point that most of
the stuff that Miss Gibson came out with
was news to me so this answer relates
very much just to the last few words
that she said really
um hydrogen is being investigated as an
option for heavy Goods vehicles in Kent
for example Rising her and Bay will be
the first supplier and distributor of
hydrogen in the area
the conversion of larger vehicles to
hydrogen is also an option to be
considered when deciding upon the route
forwards we will work with KCC and our
neighboring districts to facilitate the
installation of Technologies which will
enable the Speedy route to lower
emission transport and route to Net Zero
overall
renewable electricity electricity such
as wind and solar power is needed to
create green hydrogen through the
electrolysis of water therefore the
infrastructure for these large energy
suppliers must also be considered thank
you
thank you very much indeed councilor
bayford
and move on to agenda item 5B question
number two from a member of the public
regarding the Margate Winter Gardens I'm
pleased to welcome Mr Clement to the
meeting Mr Clemons could you make your
way to the microphone please
oh he's not here
uh
right
um well if that's the case Mr Clement
can look forward to a written answer
uh and consequence move on to agenda
item C question number three from a
member of the public regarding the
Manson processing center I'm pleased to
welcome Miss Cooper Davis to the meeting
could you please make your way to the
microphone Miss Cooper Davis
gosh well this will be a fast meeting
won't it uh Miss Cooper Davis likewise
can look forward to a written reply
agenda item seven questions from members
of the council four questions have been
received from members of the council
this evening please note that the time
allowed for consideration of questions
from Members shall not exceed 30 minutes
I ask members to be as succinct as
possible quests agenda item 7A question
number from one from a member regarding
the replacement for birth four and five
I call upon councilor wing
thank you chair the replacement for
births four five has now been in place
for a number of months and is clearly
being used by Brits but can you confirm
when they will be applying to KCC for
the fitting of the conveyor system to
ensure they can discharge both sand and
Aggregates from their vessels into their
cement batching plant and aggregate
business the lease agreement TDC has
with Brits seems to suggest at .4
improvements that this work should have
been started and completed I think this
question goes to the leader of the
council thank you
thank you very much counseling and you
are quite right councilor Ashby
thank you Jen thank you for your
question councilor wing
conveyor has not yet been fitted to the
birth and it is solely the
responsibility of Brett Aggregates to
commission and manage it is understood
that Aggregates are planning the
provision of a new conveyor but a
program for installation has not yet
been confirmed
as indicated in the birth 45 FAQs on the
council's website Kent County Council is
the planning Authority responsible for
waste and minerals which includes
Aggregates activity North and District
Council
the question also refers to part four of
the lease agreement which references a
requirement for bretts to undertake
improvements within eight weeks of the
date of agreement
the agreement is dated the 31st of March
2006 and the Improvement reference
relates to the previous and now
decommissioned birth the requirements
therefore have no relevance to the new
birth
thank you very much councilor Ashby
councilwin do you have a supplementary
yes please uh chair uh we were told
constantly that we are responsible for
Lori's bringing gravel because gravel
can't be discharged while the birth is
inoperable given that these new delays
are not ours but our breads because they
haven't put a planning application in
can you confirm whether we are still
paying for gravel to be delivered by
Laurie and can you confirm whether we
are paying for the gravel and the
delivery or just the delivery and could
we finally see the audit of births four
or five including the total cost of
replacement including the gravel
supplies in full breakdown it's public
money and I think as the ward councilor
we have a right to see that and so do
the public thank you I'm quite happy to
wait for that answer yes counselor Wing
I was going to say that a bit of a tall
order three questions on why when night
all in one as a supplementary
um
like to you can but no one's expecting
you to cover that fully
as we are you have little faith chair
um
the first question
so I'll come back I'll do it in reverse
order so
um as per the Imo's recommendation one
of them was um for uh an audit of the
first four five which I'm pleased to
advise is underway
um the provision for the lorries to
transport the aggregate out was only our
responsibility at the point where we
have fulfilled our requirement to
provide the birth as soon as the final
document of commissioning is signed over
which is very very shortly we no longer
have responsibility for that
and
regarding the cost of going forward
obviously as soon as that is signed and
I'm led to believe that there are just a
few
High technical engineering which I can't
answer the questions to as to why it's
not got the final sign off but as soon
as the final sign off is complete
um that that would then the the cost for
the transport will be a responsibility
of threats and also to confirm that
councilor Everett and myself visited the
birth and
um it is
an amazing structure to be to be honest
and it felt quite daunting when you're
out there and because I actually assumed
it didn't move but it does move and it
was a very calm day but um it would make
a wonderful dance area and I would
advise Strictly Come Dancing to come
down there and hold their next uh
instead of going to Blackpool they could
do it on verse 4-5 we might be able to
recoup some of our of our funds from
doing that but no it is quite an amazing
engineering feat I know it has been
flawed with a lot of issues but uh
hopefully that does answer all your
questions and um
so you are chair know more about it than
what I probably thought I did now well
I'm seriously impressed and I think
we're all are as well actually well done
gender item 7B question number two from
a member regarding than its Public's
toilets I call upon councilor Bailey
councilor Bailey
thank you good evening seasons greetings
to everyone I ask questions to cancel a
cup
um so the most common complaint I hear
regards the condition and the management
of the planets public toilets uh the
council's four-year corporate statement
includes an objective to undertake a
full and thorough review of our public
toilet facilities
to my knowledge there have been toilet
surveys discussions with Town councils a
toilet working party and money allocated
in the budget for toilet refurbishment
I previously asked you about this cancer
cup if you remember about the outcome of
the toilet working party in July 2021
but I'm still not aware of a published
strategy
with only a few months remaining of this
Administration could you please update
me on the progress of this corporate
objective is there a written strategy
what does it look like and when will it
be implemented thank you
thank you councilor Bailey over to you
councilor cup
thank you chair this is uh very much one
of my favorite topic good old toilets
um and thank you councilor Bailey for
your question so we know how important
public toilets are to Planet residents
and visitors alike and we are currently
commissioning condition surveys of all
these facilities the results of which
will help shape the provision and
strategy moving forward this will allow
us to explore all opportunities for
provision of this service
in the meantime we are pleased that you
know that we aren't taking a program of
deep cleans of our public toilets during
the winter period this will mean the
specific toilets will closed for one or
two days to allow the work to take place
signs will be displayed on the
facilities ahead of each temporary
closure deep cleaning is currently
scheduled for the following facilities
cross-placed broadstairs and Mildred's
Bay accessible toilets Station Road
Westgate and West Bay accessible toilets
Morrisons College walk Margate
East Pier yard Ramsgate the Center
Margate but please be aware that there
may be unavoidable changes to the
schedule I mean in addition to this we
are undertaking external and internal
refurbishment to the Harvard Street
toilets inboard stays it is anticipated
that they will reopen on the 21st
December thank you chair
thank you councilor cup councilor Bailey
have you got a supplementary
yes thank you chair
um
the toilets have been an issue and I've
lost count of how many times that it's
been raised so
why why has it taken so long to produce
this strategy and how can we have faith
that this current survey will produce a
strategy thank you
thank you councilor Bailey uh councilor
cup are you going to do as well as your
leader
um probably not but I'll give it a go so
I think that it's it's fair to say that
uh
since we came in I I wanted to make sure
that we were looking at the toilets and
finding a way to actually put them in a
condition that was acceptable for
residents and also uh tourists that are
coming down to visit our beautiful
Coastline for the the strategy has been
incredibly frustrating there have been
conversations that have gone on that has
that have with parish councils and town
councils which have made the strategy be
put back a couple of steps and we've had
to reevaluate things
um we are now going down a course where
we are very open to options and it is
being worked on and I hope and I do
believe that we will be publishing the
strategy uh in the new year
um which will explain everything and I
think that the council will be very
pleased with the strategy
thank you chair
thank you councilor cup now agenda item
seven to see is a question from uh the
councilor Everett who's not with us this
evening and therefore he will receive a
written answer
uh
uh
yes so Council bayford you are off the
hook
question number four regarding waste
management and recycling I call upon
councilor Austin
thank you chair and apologies but it's
councilor bayford again
um we all know waste management and
recycling are challenging in thanet in
Ramsgate we establish a litter Forum
five years ago to link voluntary groups
with TDC and RTC to improve Street
cleanliness and recycling rates we've
consistently requested small Street
recycling bins so we were pleased in
October to hear these would be installed
across than it we also heard with
approval plans to remove large
commercial bins from public areas to tap
tackle the fly-tipping they always
attract
so when an army of large new
commercial-sized bins for both Recycling
and litter appeared without warning on
Ramsgate streets recently as well as a
few of the small Street recycling bins
we've been promised we were
understandably puzzled and disappointed
we can only conclude that TDC policy on
managing Street waste has changed
radically since October for Ramsgate at
least could Council of bayford therefore
please explain our current approach and
the rationale for these changes thank
you
thank you Council Austin
councilor bayford your Plate's full yeah
thank you chairman thank you Council
Austin
um we are currently reviewing the usage
of bring sites and accessibility for
those residents who are unable to
receive a recycling collection from
their home
as a result of this we're trialling the
implementation of 1100 liter mixed
recycling bins at 16 different locations
throughout thanet whereby residents and
members of the public can recycle
bottles cans tins and Plastics
these locations are strategic based on
the location of properties not receiving
the recycling collection to make it
accessible within walking distance and
also to reduce fly tipping the 20
Jubilee Style mixed recycling bins have
now been installed and that includes
four in Ramsgate town as well as a 360
liter bin housing for mixed recycling to
be installed outside Canby Street
toilets
thank you councilor B for counselor
Austin do you have a supplementary
do thank you chair thank you councilor
bayford and it's it's useful to know
that that these locations are across
planet we certainly seem to have about
half of those large bins I think in in
Ramsgate but obviously we're great fans
of recycling we want to see this work
but we are concerned about the fly
tipping implications we've already seen
a great deal of fly tipping around these
bins in roundsgate my question though
really is I'm part of councilor Curry's
working group on more effective working
between TDC and town and Parish councils
why wasn't there any discussion at all
with or Parish councils about this we
know of none in Ramsgate none with the
voluntary group The Umbrella group that
we've been working with TDC for years it
would have been really helpful if we
could have had a bit of a discussion
about that known about it before they
simply landed on our streets thank you
thank you councilor Austin and oversight
councilor bayford
I wonder if it was an oversight that's
all of course it wasn't an oversight how
could you suggest such a thing I mean
look I think the fact is Council Austin
that uh communication between TDC and
town councils has improved a lot you've
got your litter Forum I know that our
environmental manager regularly attends
that and I've attended when I've been
able to
um I think we're the point really to
make is that why some recycling is a
responsive service we're constantly
getting information about the usage of
bins that are out there the failure of
the bins if you like with litter around
the place and constantly we're looking
at ways to reduce these things and this
latest
iteration is in order to actually keep
that going
um it's not possible I I don't believe
all reasonable to expect that every time
there's an operational decision made
that that should be discussed or
communicated before it's done I mean
we're only doing things because we think
that they're the right thing to do which
is all I can say but hopefully the
communication you will agree is much
better than it has been in the past and
let's hope in the future that you'll
think it's good again
thank you very much councilor bayford
agenda item 8 notice of motion one
motion of notice has been received in
accordance with Council procedure rule
three please note that the time allowed
for consideration of the motion shall
not exceed 30 minutes I ask members to
be as succinct as possible
under agenda item 8A the motion
regarding the requesting of additional
government resources I call upon
councilor Duckworth
I have councilor Duckworth here for this
well I've jumped Pages here
well we can put this down to a mistake
in the paperwork and also my dodgy
eyesight
chance well you would though wouldn't
you because you'd like to
no not at all you're not a very tolerant
councilor Bay for this evening are you
so I have the wording of the motion as
such fanet District Council supports the
campaign for thanet to become a plastic
free community reducing the flow of
single-use plastic onto our streets and
beaches
thanet District Council agrees to one
put a member on the local plastic free
Fanny Steering group number two support
plastic free communities initiatives in
this area three review the progress
already made in the removal of single
use plastic items from its premises and
operations and use the information
gathered to create a realistic realistic
timeline for complete completion of the
process now don't anyone say I fall down
on the job again
um you've just read out the whole of the
motion chair and um and and uh oh yes
she has
and uh and uh can't catch that was sat
down because you've said all of the
Motions here so I just want to vote that
out to your chair that so yeah thanks
for speaking chair thank you thank you
very much indeed well look in the
circumstances I've overstepped the
market councilor Duckworth would you
like to reread your version no councilor
Doug Quest you have a second
would you like to say a few words in
support of your motion yes please
uh what I thought I'd do is just give
you a bit of background in case you
don't know um who plastic free Thanos
are Etc so plastic free than it is a new
campaign launched on the 31st of July
2022 that aims to reduce the amount of
things we use plastic that ends up on
our beaches and streets it is part of
the surface against sewage plastic free
communities movement and is using their
five-step plan
adapted for the local context
one engaged the local Council then a
district council passes a resolution
supporting Journey's plastic free
community status to recruit business
Champions work with businesses to help
them remove three items a single use
help them remove three items a
single-use plastic from their business
to achieve plastic free champion status
three work with Community allies link
with litter groups local charities Arts
institutions and schools to educate the
community about being plastic free and
fun creative ways for community actions
events partner with Community groups to
run events with a focus on reducing
plastic waste or to join events they're
running to promote the cause five former
Steering group with representatives from
the council local business the creative
and cultural sector local media
Southeastern Railway and Southern water
to meet twice yearly to drive the
campaign forward
what is plastic free community
service against sewage initiative to
free where we live from unnecessary
single-use plastic it's Community
Network across the UK that's tackling
single-use plastic from the beach all
the way back to the brands and
businesses who create it plastic free
communities our volunteer initiatives
run by Community leads who use the
service against surge five-point plan to
transform attitudes and behaviors around
plastic within their communities
surface against sewage sets each
Community targets for business signups
and Community engagement in order to
achieve plastic-free Community status
so I will read the motion in full again
and um
Planet District Council supports the
campaign for that to become a plastic
free community reducing the flow of
single-use plastic onto our streets and
beaches Planet District Council agrees
to put a member of the local plastic
free furnace Steering group
support plastic free community
initiatives in its area review the
progress already made in the removal of
single-use plastic items from its
premises and operations and use the
information gathered to create a
realistic timeline for completion of the
process thank you
thank you councilor Duckworth and may I
say I thought you introduce your motion
much better than I could have done
Do you have a seconder
thank you councilor Auburn
would members please note that in
accordance with the council procedure
rule 3.7 if the motion is seconded then
it will be referred to Cabinet as it
relates to a cabinet function unless
otherwise Council decides to debate the
motion if Council wishes to debate the
motion then following the debate the
motion will be referred again to Cabinet
in accordance with the council procedure
rule 3.8 A4 in accordance with Council
procedure rule 3.7 a member of the
controlling political group is entitled
to reply I call a con counselor bayford
yeah thank you chairman I mean at this
stage we're very happy to have the
debate
um totally in agreement with this
um I just hope that that members will
not try your patience any further than
that tonight and not keep repeating
stuff because otherwise we could be for
a very long time covering not very much
ground
yes thank you for that
I'm grateful now do I have a proposal a
second to debate the motion
counselor Alban would you like to
propose I'd propose that we debate do
you have a secondary
well I've got councilor bayford now so
uh he'll do so can I start off who would
like to start the debate oh yeah yes we
do need a vote on that those in favor of
debating the motion please raise your
hand
and that is a majority I think yes
anyone against
nope any abstentions no who would like
to leave the blue bait
counselor Piper
thank you Mr chairman um I think this
motion along with all kinds of motions
that are bought before this Council
um
suffers there's just one thing missing
and that is how much is it going to cost
and who's going to pay it
um words like working with supporting
and coordinating and running
usually out in the real world
require the injection of some funding
so whilst not giving away one way or the
other whether I support the motion or
not I would simply say I think Motions
like this would read better and could be
responded to better if there was a
financial element to what the council
might be being asked to do
uh and because budgets don't just happen
overnight as we'll hear from the leaders
report in a moment the team have been
working extremely hard with a very
limited budget that we have so even the
best ideas sometimes you've got to find
the money from somewhere to do it so I
would just make a plea for some
inclusion of financial commitment to be
able to support motions such as these
for the benefit of our community
thank you councilor Piper a good point
Council bayford
well thank you chair
um my TDC supports the need to reduce
plastic in society especially single-use
plastic we understand the impact
single-use plastic has in our
environment and especially our beaches
over the past year TDC has run a
successful sustainability Steering group
a large number of community groups have
attended these meetings
officers have worked with these groups
to complete projects such as installing
new Bins to recycle plastic bottles
along the coast
we want to continue to support
initiatives such as these within our
resources and finances
with regards to our own Estates we've
removed plastic cups from all meetings
and continue to encourage staff to
reduce personal use of single-use
plastics
with regards to single-use Plastics in
our own operations we will consider
communicating with suppliers to request
that they reduce these in our purchases
and we will consider alternatives to
plastic materials wherever possible what
I would like to do chair and I learned
this is the right time but I'd like
partly following on from what council
Piper said to make a slight amendment to
what's being proposed so we support the
motion with with support putting a
member on local plastic free than it
Steering group uh support plastic free
communities initiative in its area with
the addition of within our available
resources and finances
and number three review the progress
already made in the removal of single
used plastic items from its premises and
operations and use this information
gathered to create a timeline to remove
single-use plastic and I want to add
we're realistic and within our control
and our resources
thank you for that councilor Beaufort um
the thing is that it's not appropriate
to have an amendment here but it's a
cabinet to make that amendment when it
goes to Cabinet you've had advanced
warning of what's going to happen at
cabinet then chair
I have I think we all have
I know that we're all going to look
forward to it are there any other
speakers councilor Alban
yeah thank you chair um I fully support
what councilor bayford has just has just
said uh in relation to his Amendment
um I just wanted to go back on what
counts what council of Piper said on
such a motion as this it's very
difficult for an individual counselor to
come to come forward with emotion and
with costings on such a wide-ranging
thing like we've just discussed or we
are discussing so um I'll take his point
on if it's to get
I don't know 20 new vehicles or
something I can understand that of
getting across but something like this
is it you can't do it but um
I fully support what councilor bayford's
just just said and I'm hoping that all
members will vote in favor of this
motion thank you
thank you very much for that councilor
Auburn are there any other speakers on
there councilor Wing yes Council well
done yes I saw you I think this gives us
an opportunity to to also recognize what
the council's already done and I don't
know whether this is uh a coincidence
but I have noticed on my street and in
my world that planning notices are now
being put up with string and not cable
ties I don't know whether they've run
out of cable ties and somebody's just
found a baller string but I would see a
reducing removing cable ties and
introducing a ball of string would be a
cost saving and I agree with councilor
Alvin that it's very difficult for an
elected member to actually work out what
what the the cost savings will be all I
will tell you is that broadstairs
Council I believe have already
introduced this this motion and
thankfully my own Council Ramsey Gate
Town Council are also looking to remove
single-use Plastics recently with within
a time frame and within the scope of our
resources and we hope to influence
others we also have events I know I've
filled in the events paperwork which is
massive there is a requirement to to
undertake recycling there and maybe some
of that that phraseology on that
paperwork can also use the removal of
single-use plastics which we do see a
hell of a lot of in some of our events
that go on on our on our on our in our
area and we give permission for so uh
you know I see this is a really positive
thing and a way of uh also promoting
what what we're already doing as a
council thank you
thank you councilor Wing
councilor councilor Yates I've got you
tonight
thank you chair
um by approving this tonight I hope we
can send a strong signal to our local
businesses schools and residents and
this will help shape our community and
result in less single-use Plastics sold
across than it and result in beaches and
cleaner streets I think one issue in
particular I just wanted to bring up is
uh disposable Vapes and what the amount
of trash and rubbish they're producing
in our area and I hope that this
committee once they are set up can
discuss that because there is no
recycling for them there's no clean
disposal for those so if that can be an
issue that'd be greatly appreciated
thanks
thank you counselor Yates Castle
Whitehead
thank you very much chair
and to a large degree as it refers to
our operations this is an extension of
the climate emergency which we
previously declared so I do feel that
this is eminently sensible
um I fully accept
the financial considerations but
I also believe that's something that can
be worked on in terms of looking at the
detail of this when it goes to Cabinet
as mentioned by councilor bayford so yes
for the in support thank you
counselor
thank you chair
um absolutely fully support this
um
I think a lot of it originated from I
did a litter pick on Margate
um Sands one Saturday night and it led
to conversations with the various groups
that were there that day and there was
also a lot of
volunteers people that are just out for
a walk actually joined us on the beach
and councilor Yates you were you were
there as well and um
I think we should first of all thank all
of the groups that that come together to
collect this but of course
we're all in control of our own destiny
here and
um the pressure really needs to come
from all of us not just as a council but
generally how we live but also the
ultimate pressure comes from from the
children you know the people of the
future so
um I would very much welcome this but we
can not stop pushing the message out
there that we are all in this together
and the children are the ones that will
probably help it deliver by putting the
pressure on from where it starts
um regarding the the littering of
plastics so
um I fully support this
um and be foolish not to as it was sort
of started by me in the first place so
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby and of course is also true uh
Castle Roth
thank you chair I strongly support this
motion I also would like to suggest uh
we have somebody worked for businesses
schools and all our workplaces will join
this recycling free like in the past
this Council had pride inside the world
for Hospitality we can have pride in
Planet for a plastic free thank you
thank you councilor Roth um oh do I
councilor cup yes
thank you chair just to follow on from
what the leader said um I think these
items are so important that I I will
raise it uh with our newly established
youth Council because I think this is a
great discussion for them to have and
see what influence they can have on this
this uh impact that is so important
thank you
quite well made uh I think we've uh that
concluded have I got anyone else no I
don't think so thank you very much well
that motion will now be forwarded two
cabinet for their consideration thank
you very much members agenda I had some
nine the leaders report I call upon the
leader counter Ashby
thank you chair sorry I drifted off
there
I was still out on the beach and Margate
Sans uh back in July
in
although not outwardly visible the
cabinet had been busy working with the
finance team and the service directors
putting together the draft budget for
2023-24
the Star Chamber approach was highly
productive and our appreciation goes to
the service directors for submitting
realistic growth plans along with
constructive ideas on savings and
importantly Revenue generation
Chris bundell has set up various budget
briefing sessions starting starting in
early July which I hope as many members
as possible will attend to in order to
enable good scrutiny and positive input
work continues on updating the local
plan for
2031 to 2040 and following the call for
sites a map of the sites has been
published on the website I noticed it's
taken up quite a lot of interest out out
there in the in the wider public no
decision and I must emphasize this has
been made about any of the sites which
which might be included within the final
version and at this stage the sites are
being assessed for the suitability on
specific purposes such as housing or
Employment Development
congratulations to our visitor
information service selected as
finalists in the visitor information
service of the Year category
the beautiful South awards for
excellence 2223 guaranteeing either gold
silver or bronze to be announced on
Tuesday the 13th of December at a
ceremony in Brighton
the process has started to find a new
operator for Ramsgate open-air market
and potential operators will be invited
to submit their expressions of Interest
which will be evaluated by a panel at
the end of the marketing period
once the preferred operator has been
selected procurement and due diligence
will follow along with stakeholders
engagement
the bathing water report for 2022 was
released by defra last week and of our
13 designated bathing Waters eight have
been classified as excellent and five
classified as good
Viking Bay has improved from sufficient
to good meaning that all of the district
bays are now classified as either
excellent or good
within our 19 miles of stunning
Coastline there is a big Reliance on the
support of many different individuals
groups and organizations to help
maintain and manage such an extensive
stretch of coast
a new Coastal stakeholder group is being
formed to provide a forum for local
organizations and partner agencies to
share information on their initiatives
and activities with a focus on the
thanic coast
keeping our streets clean we know is a
priority for local people and requires a
lot of resource to achieve
to support this it is planned to
introduce a pspo on atherstone and
ethelbert Rose in cliftonville which
should reduce the amount of litter and
other ASB in the area
a public consultation is underway to
give residents the opportunity to
comment
the sustainable wealth Grant has been
launched which is available to
homeowners and tenants to apply for for
Home Improvements free of charge if they
wish to have both home and if they won't
sorry if they were free of charge if
they have both a home with a low energy
rating and a net household income of
below 30 000.
this is particularly relevant at a time
when Energy prices as we know are
extremely high so I urge members to let
as many residents know about the scheme
as possible
there is a program of deep cleansing as
we heard earlier of our public toilets
taking place over the winter period and
as a result some of the toilets will be
closed for one or two days to allow the
works to take place repairs are also
being carried out at Harbor Street
toilets in broadstairs
20 recycling bins have been purchased
with with the first of these installed
on North Dam Road the remaining bins
will be installed and are high streets
and town centers location by March 2023
I'm delighted that last week saw the
launch of the Senate youth Council for
local 14 to 18 year olds 15 young people
attended the inaugural meeting and
discussion discussed issues such as
knife crime public transport violence
against young people bins and Parks we
now hear they're going to talk about
plastic free than it as well
congratulations to councilor cup and
Penny button and her team for driving
this initiative forward and I'm sure
that we can all learn a lot from this
young group of people finally I would
like to wish you all a very Merry
Christmas and a healthy New Year
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed councilor
Ashby I call upon councilor Whitehead to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report councilor
Whitehead
thank you chair and thank you leader
many thanks to the leader for her report
and I would also like to express how
very pleased I am with the level of
Engagement we have heard from officers
in relation to budget information
the more information is made available
the more effective we all are as a
chamber and I joined the leader in
thanking the officers involved and look
forward further briefings
with so much changing and so frequently
in relation to the leveling up and
regeneration bill
the future of development in this area
is something that is of great concern to
Residents especially in relation to the
call for sites
successfully decoding exactly what is
meant by government government
announcements regarding the future of
planning he's becoming a bit of an art
and I look forward to hearing from
central government exactly what is meant
by flexibility on future housing targets
and hope that it is directly linked to
an increase in funding for Council and
genuinely affordable housing and the
removal of the Reliance on private
developers to deliver affordable housing
as realistically that is the only way to
ensure that the future development we
have is the future development that we
actually need
as the leader states it is important to
remember that the sites listed are only
the sites that have been put forward at
this point
the legitimacy of proposals and the
future of proposed sites comes under the
next part of the process
I am very aware from Ramsgate colleagues
just how important the future of the
Ramsgate Open Air Market is and I
welcome any progress on this front
High streets and town centers are
undergoing ever tougher times as the
continuing cost of living crisis affects
our area and community-based income
generation to support them is a priority
it is excellent news that our recent
bathing water quality tests radar Bays
is either excellent or good
however the continuing Coastal
discharges make this rating an error of
Greater importance rather than simply
welcome news
we still require stronger Central
legislation to enforce the protection of
our Coastline or the tourism economy
that we rely on so strongly will
continue to be endangered alongside our
year-round water quality
I welcome the ethelstone Neville pspo
and commend the continuing efforts of
Eden Getters and all officers involved
it is easy to look at the difficulties
of an area and require changes
it is far less easy to actively make
those changes and the realities of our
demographics as an area means that I
especially welcome the focus on the
requirements of landlords to support and
ensure that residents can easily abide
by the terms of the pspo
I especially welcome the warm homes
Grant as we are all very aware that
there are many residents now in private
or owned accommodation who are
struggling significantly with the cost
of living crisis and with heating
providing for all our residents is
incredibly important and I welcome this
provision
the deep cleaning of our public toilets
is vital and also welcome
but understanding the future of them is
essential and as discussed earlier I
look forward to hearing from Council
look up in the new year as to how we
will move forward considering the lack
of statutory support for toilets
provided by central government
and finally I would like to thank rise
and the homelessness team for the work
they are putting in over this period of
the severe weather emergency protocol
it is always a period of intense work
and it's more important than ever at the
moment
thank you to all officers and members
and residents who have worked so hard
across this year and I wish everyone a
Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year
I hope that the new year brings you
everything that you need the best of
what you want and nothing to harm or
hinder you thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead well with
all of that I can't go too far wrong can
I Council of Ashby would you like to
respond
thank you chair
I didn't actually pick any questions up
there but um actually we're totally on
the same page I think throughout the
whole report so um again
um I look forward to the definition of
flexibility and non-mandatory or
whatever terminology you use but
I'm just pleased that this is this has
happened because all along oh well for
the for as long as I can remember I've
been saying that we can't
we can't drive
um the change here
we can we can object to Applications we
can protest we can do whatever but we
always had to attack
the top level and that's exactly what
we've been doing and certainly I can say
that the drum that that we that I've
been banging and that we've been banging
down here and the reports that have
written and the letters that we've
written obviously haven't fallen on deaf
ears and also the the Avid campaign of
um sir Roger Gale who have constantly
made mention to the powers that be it
took
um Secretary of State obviously two
sit-ins at the job he sort of went away
obviously the time that he had when he
was away from being the Secretary of
State allowed him to to actually
consider things I mean it will possibly
make a huge difference to us and all we
can do is keep writing and putting our
case but I really do think that fanet is
completely on the map as far as
Westminster and d-luck are concerned
they certainly know who we are and where
we are now and they certainly know that
we've got a lot to say on lots of
different matters and this is one that
affects everybody so um thank you for
that uh endorsement there the water
quality I agree I continue to sit on the
task force group and we know that it is
important here
and we can only keep pushing for for
what we for for the solutions there are
various uh
schemes that are coming up and we will
be hearing about them very shortly from
the suds program and I also look forward
to the toilet strategy something that
has been going on for a long long time I
think I set it up back in 19 2019 2018
so um here we are we've come round and
we we're nearly there and I look forward
to the end result thank you chair
thank you thank you very much councilor
Ashby I call upon councilor Garner to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leader's report councilor Garner
thank you chair
Merry Christmas
yeah
um as usual I'd like to start by
thanking the leader for the early site
of a report to allow us to prepare our
responses
there are a few items of Interest by the
all of interest but a few of them are
fewer for them that I'd like to comment
on this evening
regarding the budget now I know that
Chris and all his team are working hard
with you to prepare this over the next
few weeks and that there are plenty of
opportunities for all of us to get
involved our group will certainly be
fully participating in the process of
scrutinizing and offering up a number of
suggestions when we meet
the local plan is quite rightly a Hot
Topic and as has been mentioned it
became a little hotter earlier this week
when the government announced a number
of changes to their leveling up and
regeneration bill which will impact this
we call for the current review to be
halted earlier this year so that the
ridiculous housing numbers were being
asked to add to our Target could be
reviewed and pleased that you agreed and
wrote to the minister
in our scenes that the government are
not only going to be abandoning the
centralized mandatory targets but also
enabling stronger regulation of the
short-term holiday lets
an area that's certainly been making it
more difficult for our residents looking
for long-term rents
when the local plan review is picked up
in the new year we'll be pushing to work
towards incorporating more sustainable
housing policies in a plan that sets out
our own housing targets to meet the
needs of our local area this can't be
done through further decimation of our
green spaces and agricultural land but
can be done among other things through
using brows and field sites where
required and making sure that those
properties which are built are made
available for those who need them as
homes rather than being bought and kept
empty as Investments or adding to the
growing list of holiday lists
he is of course pleasing to see that our
bathing water around all the Bays is now
classified as either good or excellent
despite the reason sewage releases
following the recent storms
as you mentioned there are several
groups around the coast who work hard to
keep our beaches clean especially
cleaning up after the recent
aforementioned sewage releases and they
deserve our thanks and support for their
efforts
I'm sure a number of us will be
attending the southern water event in
Ramsgate on Monday evening to closely
question them about the changes they are
making to improve their infrastructure
to reduce the number so it releases
every time it rains
as we've seen in the results from this
year's resident survey clean streets are
a priority across the whole District an
action required is required in some
areas where littering and flight tipping
is escalated and so we also welcome the
introduction of the athelstone and
ethelbert Road's pspo conditions there
need to be urgently addressed as we know
they are adversely affecting residents
physical and mental health
we welcome the launch of the sustainable
warmth Grant and we'll be making as many
residents as possible aware of it
at the same time I'd also like to
commend the efforts of TDC KCC and other
organizations for providing information
and support
about warm Banks to Residents in these
extremely difficult times
and I'd also like to give a call out to
councilor Bailey for helping collect
that information in the single place for
residents on social media
that we need to provide food banks and
now warm Banks to help many of our
fellow residents survive the winter
should make us all sit up and think
about how we can do much better
especially those in central government
who seem to think poverty is acceptable
as long as it doesn't slip into
destitution
finally as part as a party that
Advocates lowering the voting age of 16
we welcome the establishment of the
youth Council we need to hear more not
less from young people and hopefully it
will encourage more of them to
participate at all levels of politics
local and National and make the changes
needed to secure their future on our
planet
uh and finally finally happy Christmas
to everybody
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed councilor
Gardner uh Casa Ashby I called upon you
to respond thank you
yes sir I'm grateful that uh your group
are going to support the scrutiny and uh
input into their budget it's really
important
um it takes a hell of a lot to put it
together and
um obviously there are areas that we'd
all like to
add extra notes on but uh you know
unfortunately
um
it is very stretched and councils have
to be more creative with some of their
revenue revenue streams there isn't any
further cuts that can be made we're down
to the marrow we've gone through the
bone and down to the marrow now so the
only way to actually maintain services
and to addition and to add Services is
to actually be more creative with the
revenue outside of the the
11.1 million council tax that we get if
we were to just provide statutory
services
um we actually wouldn't break even with
our 11.1 million we don't have enough
council tax income so we can be able to
support the 80 000 households that we
have in this District so you have to be
creative as the central budget
shrinks
um into uh from where it used to be to
where we are now
um yes the local plan is a Hot Topic and
as I chair the local plan KAG
um I know it's a very hot topic and um
as I said earlier we can all just keep
doing our work keep our eye on it and
keep our finger on the pulse as to what
is going on in Westminster and hopefully
we get more control over what happens in
our district and I wouldn't that doesn't
just apply to to planning that applies
the budget that applies to a lot of
things it would be really nice if we
could set our own budget and decide how
we wanted to spend our own money and so
our residents will be satisfied with
what goes on
the only thing on the short-term lets
and the Airbnb I agree
um the register would be would grant
bigger assistance to actually working
out what is going on the only downside
is that the minister didn't actually say
who was going to pay for and who was
going to administrate it that would be a
huge drain on another resource in the
council so I would be asking the
minister if he would support that by
giving us some funding if we were the
ones that had to administrate it our
teams housing teams already and planning
teams already have a big workload so
that would be
um that would be an extra strain on this
so and I'd like to obviously wish you a
very happy Christmas as well and um I
look forward to uh the new year thank
you
thanks very much indeed for that
counselor um Ashby I call upon the
Reverend Stuart Piper to comment on or
ask questions in relation to the leaders
report councilor Piper thank you Mr
chairman
leader I know you've been very busy
talking with central government
especially some of the big boys and
girls who are involved in government at
the moment so um
in your future conversations could I
make a suggestion that for the good of
thanet
flexible must mean fewer in terms of the
housing numbers fewer houses fewer sites
and that might help the minister to make
up his mind about what he actually means
it was good to read some good news about
the council's OWN
housing plans for new Council houses
that was very good to see and
congratulations of course to our housing
team who work extremely hard
the process of finding an operator for
Ramsgate Market we're obviously as
Ramsgate council is very very interested
in that and so we look forward to
finding out exactly who's going to run
it and when it's going to stop
with regard to the bathing Water Report
thank you for maintaining on our behalf
very good contact with Southern water
are all sorts of levels on all sorts of
issues I'm sure we will all benefit when
when the talking has finished and the
the rectifications that are required
have been made
the sustainable warmth Grant leader
um I only know it says here if you've
got a joint income of less than
30
000 and a home with a low energy rating
to be honest I only found out the energy
rating on my home because I put it up
for sale and they came round and they
said oh well this is there and they
asked me a load of questions about what
kind of insulation I had including how
old for example The Loft insulation was
I'm a little bit concerned that
there doesn't seem to be any advice in
how we tell people whether they've got a
poorly insulated or energy rated home
because if they simply go on the
internet and have a look what their
address was 10 years ago things may have
changed by then so I just wonder if
there's any room in all of that when
we're advising our residents if there's
any way we can advise them on how to get
up-to-date ratings and any costs that
might be involved
um and finally apart from wishing
everybody a very Merry Christmas
um well done councilor cup thank you for
excellent work with the young people uh
thank you leader for your report
thank you very much indeed councilor
Piper uh because Ashby have you got a
response thank you chair thank you for
your response councilor Harper
fewer okay
I mention that word I've got a few words
that I've mentioned to you so I'll add
that one to the list
um Council housing yes
um we have got a housing crisis in this
country and we have got a housing we've
got a crisis with emergency
accommodation as we know so I entirely
agree and um that I think personally the
only way out of this is for councils to
build up their their housing stock
and I would just love the government to
give us a few you know 100 million quid
to be able to do it but then of course
then we come into direct conflict with
the fewer rather than the flexible so
it's a balance it's a fine balance you
know we need to provide the homes but if
we are going to provide homes in thanet
then let's provide homes that people can
afford and build our own stock up all
for that
um Southern Water contact yes I do have
a lot of contact with Southern water not
always good
um but we remain in open dialogue and
hopefully I will be along there on
Monday evening
um I just hope that people attack
fun and water rather than attack me as
they did in the previous public meeting
that I attended so you know they are the
people that have got to put this right
we can only help them by by signing up
to the different schemes the energy
rating system I'm reliably informed by
our director of housing that we've
actually got two two officers that can
give advice on this or Point people in
the right direction so
um I think if we can publish uh that
advice
um to members and then you can pass that
on but uh uh yes you're right I mean the
only way is to have your energy rating
and it's usually only when when you go
to sell but might be quite a good idea
if maybe the government or or even the
housing if there's some sort of like
check Matrix that they could fill in
like a questionnaire for the items that
they do know about but I mean obviously
a lot of it is dependent on Windows
heating system and obviously the um the
Loft and the insulation and cavity
insulation but I'm not an expert on this
by the way so um I think um I can ask
the housing director to provide that
information to all members so thank you
and I'd like to wish your group as well
a very merry Christmas
thank you thank you very much indeed
lead I think what really what we're
talking about is the preparation of an
energy performance certificate which
generally goes with any house sale
uh agenda item 10 and back to you
councilor Piper as the chairman of the
overview and scrutiny panel I call upon
you to present the report
thank you again Mr chairman
um the report is here members I'm sure
you've all had a chance to have a look
at it there are just a couple of things
I would like to mention please on the
review of our work program that the
report does say that the leader is
kindly agreed to come and bring her
presentation about the efficacy of the
CAG groups to us uh in January it was as
you know due to have been in November
but we had a briefing uh about the
Manson processing center instead which
was organized at very short notice and
this is the first opportunity to thank
those involved in that in preparing that
for us but it does bring me to 2.14 in
the report there is a typo which I
missed I'm very sorry about that it says
we will be given a briefing uh we were
given a briefing
um and it was a very good briefing
indeed the rest of the report is their
member please if you wish to make any
suggestions or comments if not this
evening I'm happy to receive emails or
requests such was the case with the
Manson processing center that's what
kicked the ball off uh kick the ball
rolling in the first place thank you Mr
chairman
thank you very much today councilor
Piper do members have any comments
not this evening
gender item 11 the mid-year review
2023-2023 treasury management and annual
investment strategy I call upon
councilor David Saunders
foreign
thank you chairman
almost Char tell and Charlie are going
aren't I
um hopefully my advice will last out
there's a degree of deja vu because I
seem to have read this same introduction
only two weeks ago but there are some
changes we've made some changes to make
it less boring for you
um
this report sets out the review of the
council's mid-years treasury management
activities
at the meteor point we had approximately
20 million pound of external borrowing
no new external borrowing had been
undertaken during the first half of the
year but 168 000 pounds of debt had been
repaid during this period
despite using our internal cash balances
to fund our new borrowing needs the
council still has a significant cash and
investment balance holding almost 57
million pounds as at the 30th of
September
2022 looking forward across the
remainder of the financial year
borrowing options will continue to be
reviewed in line with current and
emerging market conditions the report
sets out some proposed minor technical
changes to our treasury management
strategy firstly to reflect a change in
accounting estimates following a further
deferral in the implementation of the
accounting standards for leases
I am assured that making the change
ensures our limits are adjusted to an
appropriate level
and all the assurances I get from my
financial team are all well founded and
absolutely spot on furthermore there is
also a proposed change to the increase
of length of time we are permitted to
invest with the UK government from six
months to two years in order to increase
our investment options
finally I do need to report a minor
breach of our investment limits
for one of our deposits not our fault
this is due to an error on behalf of one
of the council's financial providers
where they added the accrued interest
to the balance of our deposit with the
funds rather than paying the interest
directly to the council this resulted in
six million pound limit being exceeded
by 4 385 pounds for the period first
June to the C to the 8th of June 2022
and by 5 335 pounds from the first of
July to the 4th of July 2022.
this report has previously been
presented to both cabinet and the
government's an audit committee on the
17th and 30th of November respectively
and was recommended to council for
approval
I therefore move the recommendations
thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
Saunders do members wish to comment I
think we agree oh yeah sorry uh seconded
thank you very much councilor Ashby do
uh me anyone wish to comment or I think
we agree don't we with that to accept
yeah do members agree oh great yes thank
you our mask
agenda item 12 the revised members code
of conduct I upon the leader
thank you chair
I'm quite prepared for this was I am I
presenting I thought you were presenting
it chair sorry
I think we just need to move it in
actual fact um later so if you have a
seconder I think we can settle for that
councilor Pugh will second
do members agree uh Council Auburn do
you wish to say something yes please
chair
um just going through the code of
conduct here there is uh as part of the
report there's two issues in relation to
um
members
declaration limit
oh sorry big pudding
um which is the members declaration
limit uh it's recommended a hundred
pound
uh for that for that limit but it's also
given an option to stay in on a 25 pound
which which it currently is I would urge
members to to stick on the 25 pound
limit
um I think extended it to a hundred
pound it is wrong and we should and we
should remain with that
second this year
um there is the definition of
anti-semitism in which it says they may
wish part of the report said you may
wish for that to be retained we as a
council agreed it back in 2020 and I can
see no reason why that should be removed
here so um I would urge members to agree
that we retain the anti-Semitism
definition and retain the 25 pound thank
you chair
yes thanks very much calendar Auburn my
understanding is that the 25 pounds is
uh the requirement and we are retaining
the anti-Semitism clause
uh does any other member have a comment
councilor Ashby yeah um just for clarity
I did cause a bit of confusion um
[Laughter]
so the options are
um uh the option and this has come
through from the Constitutional review
working party then onto standards so the
standards was the last was the last
committee to hear it so I think I'm
writing saying that standards
put it to to it back to 25 and the
anti-Semitism law or rule applies
because that was part of what we'd
already agreed previously at Council
so the understanding is and just for
clarity and I think I have
Clarity from the
um
MO
um
so the confusion appeared to be around
the fact of the new codes did not
mention it so the new codes are not our
code so it's whether we adopt the new
code with or without these particular
elements so
um
TDC members agreed to include the
definition of anti-seminism in in their
code of conduct and it has been
recommended that it retained so just for
clarity that's where we are and we are
still at 25 pounds and I promise not to
have any bottles of champagne care
I'm still open you wish to come back yes
thank you chair
um it was just me reading a report here
uh when it says members may wish to
continue with the lower amount you know
that's that was the com that was the
confusion issue and also the same it
says the same with the anti-Semitism
within within the report here so it was
reading it and I'm pleased to hear what
the leaders just said thanks chip
right well thank you for that Council
open because that was my reading of it
as well um and I think we're all on the
same channel here now
members uh stop talking amongst
yourselves it would seem
that it does say a hundred in the
document
which is contrary to what I understood
to be the case so leader would you like
to move an amendment
yes chair just for that one item we're
okay on the other item
so um I'd like to propose an amendment
to the item that it remains at 25 pounds
um reporting allowance thank you chair
you have a second counselor I'd write a
second actually thank you very much I
thought you might our members in favor
of that Amendment
thank you any against
any abstentions
no
so do members agree
overall with the document agenda item
job thank you very much indeed
every meeting has a little bit of
confusion agenda item 13 the revised
complaint Arrangements I call upon the
leader again
thank you chair
the recommendation is for to agree the
changes of the council's standards
complaints handling Arrangement taking
into consideration the recommendations
from both the Constitutional review
working party and the standards
committee
thank you chair that is the
recommendation
Do you have a seconder
councilor Pugh do members agree
thank you very much indeed well members
look that concludes the business this
evening I personally as chairman would
like to offer my
happy Christmas to everybody in the
chamber and a happy New Year as well I
would also like you to join me for a
mince pie afterwards downstairs not very
much but just a little token to for the
festive season uh I'd like us all to put
aside any political distance differences
we might have we're all colleagues
acting on behalf of the residents of
thanet and I really would love to see
all of you uh with me for a mince pie so
thank you very much for this evening
see you hopefully later